all right so what is the democrat
position on all this because even though
they are the ones that have lied and
lied and lied they had lied about kovid
they lied about russia collusion they
lied about brett kavanaugh they lied
about jesse smilet you guys know all of
this stuff they lie about everything no
one ever gets called out well we call
them out let's say on this crazy right
wing media but in within their own
system it's a constant protection racket
you lie other people lie for you you
just work around it everybody's in on
the lie so nobody calls anybody out no
one ever gets fired nobody ever gets
booted okay fine
so what is their position as a lot of
people are clicking ben shapiro videos
on facebook as fox continues to crush it
in the ratings
as this show outperforms pretty much all
of the cable news shows on msnbc and cnn
well their position
is we need to do something related to
censorship and regulation of course here
is uh mental [ __ ] aoc who's managing
who's in charge of all these platforms
that are perpetuating this
misinformation and violence
men
mark zuckerberg
where you at bro
where you at
4chan
reddit
what's
up
because all these little things that
they're talking about when they say free
speech they don't actually mean it
because they don't they don't protect
all speech
they drew do draw a line at some point
but you know people like mark zuckerberg
are busy having dinner with tucker
carlson who's also airing little great
replacement theories that are inciting
violence and he's platforming the very
people that mass shooters are citing in
their own very clearly written
manifestos
let us dispense with this myth of mental
illness
okay after this pandemic
millions of people have struggled with
mental illness of some kind
whatever it is depression anxiety
bipolar
you know
whatev from from
mental illnesses that are less
presenting to mental illnesses that are
more presenting
this
this is not about that
this is about a trained cohesive
ideology
of hatred and violence
whether it is explicit white supremacy
that we saw in buffalo
or whether it was just simply the silos
that young men radicalize themselves in
online
for whatever reason using whatever
pretenses
i really don't think aoc is a real human
being and what i mean by that is not
that she's a cylon
but that she is a construct that that
what you're seeing there is not a real
person who believes anything that she's
saying she is an actress she is a
trained actress who does these little
videos where are you at mark zuckerberg
where are you at who do we have to blame
for this we have to blame men
they're not free everything she says is
complete nonsense and a lie and
everything else oh mark zuckerberg's
having dinner with tucker carlson so
because they're having dinner then
obviously they're in the cahoots with
each other and it's like man
man you are not a real person aoc she is
an
abject clown she is an abject clown so
why is she so afraid why is she so
afraid of tucker carlson having a show
that people watch uh and tucker carlson
doesn't do replacement theory stuff it's
the left you know this i didn't even
talk about this for the few weeks that
everyone was freaking out about
replacement theory which is not even a
phrase i've ever said on this show once
uh but it's the left that is obsessed
with replacement theory
people have pointed out that over the
last couple years they're constantly
articles in the new york times about how
the demographics in the united states
are changing and it's browning and that
that is good for democrats and that that
in essence is the replacement theory but
then when tucker carlson says that there
are demographic issues in the united
states which there obviously are there
obviously are demographic issues we can
talk about all the all the reasons uh
that people of specific ethnicities and
colors and all these things might vote
one way or another and you know if it
wasn't for the democrats constantly
screaming racism i think an awful lot of
people would not be voting for them in
the first place
but they lie about everything